every day Davi see mango does it too of
his city inspecting the reconstruction
of beylin with the destruction of
cyclone either I still visible
everywhere
the mayor's determined to stay in close
contact with the residents see mango is
trying hard but he can't always help the
mayor is part of an opposition party
after the cyclone he strongly criticized
the central government for its slow
response the city's annual budget is
only about 13 million euros it was real
very difficult we went heating heating
heating until they understood that they
need us we need they need us we need
them we need everybody that's why I
spoke to the donors I spoke to the
central government and I told him that
we need to joint forces and I'm happy
that they agreed with us by now eight
organizations are active all over town
the water supply has been restored parts
of the city have electricity again but
they are also setbacks the number of
malaria cases is on the rise and despite
mass immunizations Mozambique has
reported more than 3,500 cholera cases
Mesa mangu meets eight workers in an
improvised hospital gets an update on
the situation and wants to know how he
can help you have to talk to the people
sensitized I mean you have to tell them
how to avoid cholera they have to boil
their drinking water the doctors working
here they're still worrying because
there's still some cases coming in and
we need to stop it I hope that we are
going to do that the most part of myself
and my team to be in the ground talking
to the people advising them there the
care you need to do I'm sure that we are
going to stop it
the next problems are waiting so see
mungo is hitting the road again full of
optimism and drive despite the difficult
situation I feel a challenge
I feel a challenge I feel that something
has to be done and
I feel as a part of person who has to do
something
so I feel great I feel
as a person who has choice to face this
disaster is a personal choice by God to
face all the challenges when people see
mangoes next big plan a donor conference
in May he wants to collect more eight
money for the reconstruction of his city
so the people of Beira can live here
once again like they did before cyclone
we died let's get more now we are joined
by our correspondent Adrian Krrish he is
in the airport there in Beira
where the humanitarian response is being
coordinated and Adrian you know from
your piece that we've just seen there we
saw a bit of the situation or a window
into the situation in Beira
how do things look further outside in
rural areas though in Mozambique I went
further outside about three hours
outside the bay by yesterday to town
called guau guau
a three-hour trip I rode on a very bad
road in the situation there are still
much worse you can imagine the people of
then in more poverty even so that many
of them just way the worst thing for now
as though that also all the crops were
blown away I went with an old lady on
her field she showed me all the maize
was gun she has nothing to eat anymore
she completely relies on on food aid and
she said it will take her at least six
months until she can grow things and
harvest there an amazed again so this is
the time and for all this time there
and adriaen we have to mention it's not
the first time that Barbara has been hit
by a natural disaster the city has seen
many floods in the past top of us a
little bit more about preparedness and
with coping in the future or efforts
even to prevent further disasters like
this right the city tried to react
already many years ago a few years ago
they started constructing a drainage
system through the city center that was
a multi-million euro project also
supported by several governments from
Europe amongst them Germany and the
mayor told me that without that system
in place it would have been even a
bigger disaster here because Beira was
lucky in a sense that it was only hit by
the cyclone at least the city center and
the flats were not as bad as they were
outside in the rural area so this
project really helped but it is not
enough it is just in one part of the
city and in other parts the situation is
still really terrible if you think of
more flats possibly to come in the next
year's you have a lot of parts of the
town that are bordering directly to the
sea and when you go there you can see
how close the sea came over the years
several rows of houses where already
taken by the sea and I talked to people
living there they said well we would
love to live somewhere else but we can't
afford it but we know that in the future
our houses are really under threat as
well
Adri on krish in barra thank you